j'offre un cadeau à Squeezie il ne s'y
attendait pas du tout souviens avec quoi
tu filmais ou pas bah au début on se
filme à la webcam puis ensuite je volais
le petit appareil photo numérique de ma
mère et puis ensuite mon père il m'a
offert ma ma première caméra HD qui
était oh comment tu as fait oh c'est
trop fort et tu sais que c'est ma
relique là tu as ma relique entre les
reins parce que je vois l'écran il a il
est il non mais c'est littéralement vra
il y a ça qui s'ouvre un peu trop je
dire c'est pas le tu as retrouvé le
modèle quelque part c'est le vrai que
j'ai chez moi c'est littéralement la
tienne je tiens comme si c'était ton
c'était ton déj c'est sacré pour moi ça
a changé ma vie ce petit objet c'est
incroyable